well this well the semester is a
traditional exercise of coordination in
our economic policies I think that today
we have a new strong message and the
message is that we will bring
environmental sustainability fully into
the European semester framework when we
say that the European Green Deal is our
strategy for growth we mean it
fundamental to this strategy as
well.this said before is the integration
of the United Nations sustainable
development goals in the semester I want
to be very clear on the fact that this
is a process we are in some way in it in
a transition with this communication it
is a process that the places of the
process are already in this document
then we will you will see change already
in February with our counter reports
because analysis of sustainability
challenges will be in the country
reports and then gradually during the
year we will add this fundamental
element to macroeconomic surveillance
and social pillar which are already
fundamental in our strategy having said
this the the point on the euro area
recommendation this recommendation
provides direction for policies
affecting the euro area
because we need to think of the euro
area as one economic entity in need of
great coordination of course
coordination doesn't mean uniformity the
challenging facing euro area countries
remain very diverse this is clearly
reflected in our call for member states
with current account deficits to boost
complete competitiveness and reduce the
external debt and for those with large
current account surpluses to support
wage growth and foster investment we
make a specific call to the euro area
member states to support a fair and
inclusive transition towards a
competitive green and digital economy
through tangible and intangible
investment above both public and private
the review of our fiscal governance next
year is clearly relevant for the public
the completion of the capital markets
union for the private investment in case
of a worsening outlook and this is where
the coordination part comes in the euro
area as a whole should have a supportive
fiscal stance we also call all the euro
area countries in this recommendation to
support and implement actions to combat
aggressive tax planning and address a
race to the bottom in corporate taxation
all countries also need to strengthen
their the education and training systems
and boost investments in skills while
purchasing other reforms to make labour
markets more inclusive and Nikolas will
say more on these issues in a moment I
will also like to stress the importance
of our recommendation related to the
completion of the banking union and the
capital markets Union
ambitious progress on the European
Deposit Insurance Scheme is key to
ensuring that we have a truly balanced
package when it comes to deepening the
economic and monetary union this in turn
is crucial in order to strengthen the
International role of the euro and to
project Europe's economy economic
interests global these police reactions
that we recommend to euro area are
urgent in order to rebuild trust and
provide a boost to confidence in the air
and finally let me say a few words on
the alert mechanism report but as you
know this report identifies countries
that have or that may have macroeconomic
imbalances which could pose a risk to
stability which as well.these said
before is one of our four main tracks
the good news is that we are not
proposing any in-depth reviews for new
countries our report concludes that the
same 13 member states which underwent an
in-depth review one year ago should
again be analyzed these are Bulgaria
Croatia Cyprus France Germany Greece
Ireland Italy the Netherlands Portugal
Romania Spain and Sweden risks to
macroeconomic stability continuing
receding on the back of ongoing economic
growth but vulnerabilities persist
depths level remain too high and some
emerging trends require careful
monitoring let me mention to conclude a
few of these trends specifically one
though the euro areas current account
surplus has come down very slightly is
12 still over 3 percent of GDP in 2018
the surplus this surplus remains the
largest in the world
and is estimated to be around double the
level suggested by economic fundamentals
unit labor costs had kept growing
strongly especially in central in
Eastern Europe and the Baltic countries
and to a lesser extent in the euro area
private sector debt reduction has
continued but it's space as eased
especially as regards our whole depth in
some countries private debts burdens
have increased where they were already
high in a few countries high public debt
ratios are not declining the banking
sector is stabilizing but challenges
remain in a number of countries where
banks have relatively low capitalization
and profitability and relatively high
costs ratios of non-performing loan and
ratios of non-performing loans the
outlook for low for long interest rates
and weakening growth is adding to those
challenges lastly house prices have
continued growing at high rates and more
countries risk become overvalued and
with that I will hand the floor to
Nikolas meteor valleys Messi Paolo